hello everybody it's Joe the locksmith
in this video we'll make a key all keys
lost for 2018 Honda Accord push to start
using the hotel I am 608
first we'll generate the universalide
key we'll go to Universal key
accept
Universal key generation
North America
Honda
type by model
Accord
should be this one here g0090
or click generate Universal key
continue generation
press complete
and now get ready to program the key
email
except
Honda
manual selection
Accord
Swan key
push to start
yes
control unit
keyless system Honda
is the ignition turned on by pressing
stop button twice it's all keys lost
we'll say no
press and hold the stop button
down
oh
[Music]
okay
all keys lost
ignition off
[Music]
okay
see no
press and hold
[Music]
okay
so let's say no
I just want to line one key
one
okay
ignition off
ignition on one
two times
yes the lights are off we say yes
ignition off
ignition on
okay ignition is off
okay 10 ignition switch on
all right that completes our procedure
Let's test out the key
ignition off
unlock Works Lock Works
try to start the car
she's a runner
2018 Honda Accord oh Keys loss using the
autel im608 and the universal I key
thanks for watching have a great day